and then there's jalen hurts who became
the starter after 12 games last year
because carson wentz was benched and now
the eagles remember after they reached
the deal to trade carson wentz to
indianapolis what we heard was the
eagles are still looking they're still
looking for another quarterback they
want competition the eagles very well
documented as a team that views the
backup quarterback position as a top 15
spot on the total roster
now
courtesy of chris morton of espn the
notion that jeffrey lurie wants to
support jalen hurts in 2021
not create competition and that is a
very subtle but important distinction
when it comes to finding a backup
quarterback because there's two kinds of
backup sharing there's the backup who
knows
he's the backup and who knows his job is
to support and teach and help the
starter then there's the backup who has
license to compete fully and completely
and if he ultimately can push the
starter to the bench so be it now i
remember matt hasselbeck used to say
when he was backing up andrew luck his
attitude was to try to create a sense of
competition with andrew luck even though
no one thought that there was actual
competition so there's different ways
you support the starter but it sounds
more like
the eagles are going to be looking for a
number two who is more of a support
person
which points to
super bowl 52 mvp in my mind nick foles
being the guy who is on the roster with
hertz because he won't try to topple
hertz he will be available in the event
that hertz gets injured and they need
someone to come in so he fills that role
of backup quarterback who can get it
done if need be but they can support
jalen hurts and help him become the best
quarterback that he possibly will be in
the nfl
yeah you've said foals all along mike
and it does make a lot of sense right
for him to come back there i mean he
we've decided that he's never going to
be a full-time starter in the nfl i mean
most games he's ever started in this
season is 11 but he's a great backup one
of the best backups in nfl history and
if jalen hurts struggles or gets hurt or
whatever he is perfect to go in there
and he's also going to have a
relationship with jalen hurts even as he
backs up jalen hurts i mean we saw it
with him with carson wentz we did not
see that carson wentz with jalen hurts
jalen hurts talked about that with adam
schefter uh this week about how they
they really didn't have that
relationship uh that that perhaps carson
wentz had with nick foles because nick
foles knows his place right so he does
make perfect sense there and he's not
going to come in and push jalen hurts
but he is going to come in and make
jalen hurts a better quarterback i'm
just not positive mike that i've seen
enough from jalen hurts to know he's
their guy and maybe that's what they're
trying to figure out maybe they've
decided with all their salary cap
problems we can't content we can contend
in the division there's no question
about that it's a bad division we know
that but we can't contend for a super
bowl right now so let's go see what we
have in jalen hurts this season and
prepare to come back in 2022 and the
salary cap is more we have this high
pick we can go use to get some weapons
around him or whatever we deemed we need
to use those high picks on but let's go
get help for jalen hurts and see what we
have in him but it almost reminds me of
the drew lock situation i mean they
started almost the same amount of games
and we thought locke had shown enough to
be the guy and it turns out he he didn't
this year showed that he was the guy so
i want to see more from jaylen hurts and
maybe that's what the eagles are waiting
on to see more from jalen hurts mike
and let's not be naive either they are
at number six in the draft and to the
extent that they are thinking about
using that sixth overall pick on a
quarterback it is in their interest to
create the impression
that they're not and no one trust me if
the eagles go quarterback at number six
no one maybe i will now that i'm
thinking of is gonna dust off chris
mortensen's report from today and give
it the same kind of 11 of 12 attention
that a report of his got six years ago
and say he's wrong they were looking for
another quarterback but that's the thing
if you are thinking about a quarterback
there you need to get people to think
you aren't because then when it's time
for the bengals to tie these two
together to trade down from number five
you're more likely to get the bengals
attention and get someone to jump up
because you know you need to get up in
front of
the philadelphia eagles to get a
quarterback depending upon who's left at
that five spot so yeah we don't want a
quarterback we don't want a quarterback
we don't want a quarterback and then
maybe the rest of the league will think
they're not looking quarterback at sixth
overall it would be naive and foolish to
rule that out because of the way the
draft works but let's assume it's the
truth let's assume they're all in with
jalen hurts i agree with you
i don't think there's enough evidence
yet to know what he's going to be and
one of the problems last year he started
so late in the year there wasn't enough
film to give defenses a full
understanding of who he is what he is
what he does what he doesn't do
how to properly defend against him and
now this year with a new offense and i
don't know how much the nixoriani
offense is going to be similar to or
different from what doug peterson did
but it's going to take some time to get
the film to understand how are they
using him where are the weaknesses how
can we deplore our 11 to match their 11
based upon the things that number two
does that may take into october and then
you have a ceiling that gets positioned
over that offense gets positioned over
jalen hurts and nick ciriani when the
defense has the film that's when we're
going to find out whether or not jalen
hurts can bust through that ceiling or
whether or not they found a way to crack
the code and the eagles can't figure out
how to counter what defenses have
figured out how to do
one thing mike they need to figure out
how to if they're truly going to build
around jalen hurts how to get getting
more weapons because i am curious carson
wentz's regression how much of that was
the fact that he just didn't have any
weapons around him i mean when i look at
that offense and i saw those receivers
and those running back there was nobody
on that offense that scared me
whatsoever we know they had all the
injuries to the offensive line he had no
protection last year so all those things
really added up for carson wentz and
then you're right jalen hurts came in
late and he had those same problems so
you've got to get some weapons around
him but let's go back to your point
about the draft i just think if you
judge these quarterbacks and you deem
one of those guys to be a franchise
quarterback i just think you have to
draft him there
you're you're unsure about jalen hurts
draft the guy let jalen hurt start off
the season you can always trade him but
i go back to what the lions did last
year with that third overall pick they
had a chance to get justin herbert and
they didn't do it and now they have a
new quarterback jared goff who we know
is not as good as justin herbert because
they traded matthew stafford and i think
they would have been better off if they
had used that third overall pick on
justin herbert today they would be
better off than where they are now and
so i just think if you deem one of those
guys to truly be special and he's there
i just think you have to draft mike
drive the quarterback
all i know is the eagles understand very
well how the media works they understand
the concept of the long con and it would
be a long con indeed to start planning
the notion now that they are not
thinking about a quarterback with that
sixth overall pick have it take root let
it become an accepted narrative and then
his teams are trying to decide on draft
night where they need to go to get mac
jones or zach wilson or whoever even if
aggie great helen mon continues his
meteoric rise fueled by chris sims into
the top ten whatever it's going to take
if teams are looking at those picks and
they scratch the eagles off as a
potential quarterback destination at six
that is mission accomplished
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports